[Music]
there are going to be about nine point
six billion people in the world by the
year 2050 and if you look at the way
that yields are increasing they're not
increasing fast enough to feed nine
point six billion people so while past
gains in agricultural productivity have
come from using more water and using
more land we're at a point where we
don't have those resources anymore the
three common themes that matter are
controlling the environment measuring
the environment and analyzing what's
going on farm view is bringing all that
together take a comprehensive view bring
all these technologies together we use
robotics for controlling we use
different types of sensor technologies
for the measurement and often the
sensors are deployed by the robots and
then we use machine learning for the
analysis we can grow more food with less
water and less land so one of the things
we need to do is transfer the kinds of
research we do in the United States to
parts of the world that really need it
so that they can create better crops
that then go to their local growers that
the growers can grow then using their
traditional methods however their food
system currently works we just give them
a better plant that makes them more
productive locally there are many small
farms that are right on the edge of
being able to survive and with the
increase in efficiency that we can
provide with better sensing and better
technologies they can stay in business
when we do this kind of work we have to
work with experts from from other fields
land-grant universities government
agencies local growers who are producing
crops we have a wide range of partners
that we work with to really bring this
stuff into the field and make sure that
we're actually solving problems that
need to be solved being that conduit
from these basic fundamental research to
solving real problems is one of the big
impacts that Carnegie Mellon can
on the world